[Música]
[Aplausos]
algunas ideas nos apasionan
nos desvelan nos hacen que solemos ver
se nos escucha bien
nos hacen que solíamos con ellas y si le
damos formas le ponemos objetivos las
organizamos se transforman la misión de
nuestras vidas la alternativa
una serie de explicaciones y de excusas
de por qué no hacemos lo que queremos
hacer
soy la segunda de tres hermanos la del
medio y una hermana mayor
la primera mujer
hija sobrina nieta la esperada y de un
hermano menor varón después de muchos
años de diferencia quien no quiere el
varón para que se ve el apellido de la
familia bueno eso era la del medio y en
esa infancia siempre sentí que debía
esforzarme para ocupar un lugar
ya de grande y mamá de cuatro hijos
entendí de que no hace falta tener una
orden para nacer uno los quiere a todos
por igual no hace falta hacer méritos
para que te quieran pero bueno soy mi
infancia sentía eso así que fui buena
alumna buena hija siempre responsable no
tan buena hermana porque en realidad mis
hermanos las perseguidas para que hagan
las cosas bien
cuando llegue al final del secundario
decidí en un momento que no iba a ser
médica cirujana como había dicho siempre
sino que iba a ser contadora pública yo
era bachiller orientación docente jamás
había visto un asiento en mi vida
bueno bueno ahí había entendido que yo
quería volver a estar cerca de mis
padres estar en un lugar que ocupo hoy y
para eso me tenía que preparar
así que aprendí asientos de contabilidad
hacia córdoba y a los cinco años era
contadora
bueno aparte de eso me apasionan otras
cosas por ejemplo soy esposa mamá hija
amiga empresaria penalista gremialista
de gremial empresaria
siempre casi siempre fui la primera
mujer en todos los cargos que ocupe y
que ocupo
y aún en mi actividad en la empresa la
mayoría son hombres el 95% mis clientes
son hombres los que venden son hombres
siempre estoy en un ámbito de hombres
pero la verdad que no siento ninguna
diferencia y pienso que si trabajamos y
tenemos ganas de hacer las cosas es lo
mismo ser mujer que ser hombre
en los distintos roles que se ocupando
siempre estuvo ahí hubo dolores hubo
cosas cosas feas
circunstancias que me hacían dudar de
seguir o no
pero nunca fueron las cosas para dejar
de lado mi pasión
por eso voy a contarle algunas pequeñas
anécdotas por ejemplo siendo presidente
cuando empecé a ser presidente de
agrometal yo tenía 39 años mi padre
falleció un viernes el sábado lo
enterramos y el domingo en mi pueblo
empezó la versión el rumor qué va a
pasar con la empresa continúa siguen se
vende
y bueno el lunes trabajamos como un día
normal a media mañana yo le digo a todos
los empleados que vayan al patio de la
empresa y agarró el micrófono y les digo
con mucha emoción porque imaginen que se
estaba despidiendo no sólo al presidente
sino a mi papá y asumiendo una
responsabilidad
muy grande de la vicepresidente de ese
mismo momento pasó a ser presidente de
la empresa
y bueno les digo de que la empresa
continuaba que hay una familia que
estaba dispuesta a continuar con la
empresa que hay un equipo de gente que
estaba dispuesto a ese desafío y que
estaba toda esta gran familia agrometal
que formaba parte y que estábamos
preparados para seguir bueno todo
terminó en un gran aplauso de despedida
a mi padre y de comienzo de mi gestión
que me sentí aceptada contenida pero fue
un momento difícil el comienzo después
como siguiente como gremial empresaria
también tuve momentos difíciles yo
participo en muchas organizaciones
representaciones del sector la cámara
fabricante de maquinarias agrícolas yo
fui presidente la primera presidente
de la cámara
y me tocó en aquella época del 2006 al
2008 cuando el 2008 fue la crisis del
campo la 125
yo represento al campo porque vendemos
máquinas para el campo así que fue un
momento difícil una crisis difícil de
estar porque sólo podía hablar en nombre
mío si no hablaba el nombre del sector
pero bueno hubo una vez que se ve que
dije algo más de lo que tenía que decir
en una en una entrevista y me llamó un
30 de diciembre a los dos o tres días de
esa entrevista el que era secretario de
comercio de ese momento quitándome que
vaya buenos aires- que quería hablar
conmigo le dije no porque yo un 30 de
diciembre no voy
bueno el 2 de enero me vino a visitar a
la empresa fue un momento difícil
pero tuvimos dos horas y se portó muy
bien y lo único que hizo fue escuchar
nuestros problemas podría haber sido una
excusa pero en realidad bueno seguí
siendo presidente de la cámara un
tiempito más hasta que se terminó mi
mandato
como mamá también he tenido momentos
difíciles por supuesto con cuatro hijos
cuando eran chiquitos grandes pero hubo
uno que me había dolido especialmente
porque lo había relacionado con el
trabajo apenas comencé con mi gestión
estaba en córdoba con marido en la
reunión y tuvimos que viajar de
emergencia a otra reunión a buenos aires
y no dormir en casa esa noche cosa que
habitualmente
yo hice siempre viajo mucho por mi
gestión en las asociaciones que estoy
las reuniones siempre son afuera en las
grandes ciudades así que por lo menos
por lo menos algún viaje por semana si
no son dos pero desde que comencé
siempre trato de regresar la noche a mi
casa para hacer de mamá ese día no
pudimos regresar y cuando llegamos a
buenos aires- hablamos por teléfono yo
notaba que había lo que nos querían
decir y bueno después de insistir mucho
me entero de que la más chiquitita que
se tenía dos años en ese momento se
había quemado con agua hirviendo en la
cocina que hay una olla
y bueno fue difícil porque tuvimos dos
meses de recuperación de llantos de
culpas pero bueno tampoco fue expulsada
para dejar de lado mi pasión
de mi padre aprendí
que la pasión
no tiene excusas
aprendí que
él nos marcó el camino nos marcó el
camino con su ejemplo de vida
y con las cosas que no fue como lo fue
enseñando
yo tengo una anécdota siempre te cuento
que como me enseñó a ser responsable y
ya no hacerme cargo de cosas que no me
correspondían como por ejemplo en el
último año del secundario
último mes del último año del secundario
imagínense que ya uno se cree que es
dueño de la escuela dueño del mundo que
ya podíamos hacer todos hacía poquito
uno o dos años que había dejado de ser
feriado el 2 de noviembre el día de los
muertos
y nosotros con mis compañeras que éramos
decidimos que ese día no íbamos nos
tomábamos el feriado es el día de los
muertos y nos íbamos a ir
entrábamos ocho menos cuarto a la
escuela siete y media me tocó y me dijo
te quedaste dormida
les cuento todo esto no mira los pasos
que nosotros no vamos a la escuela
porque el día de los muertos
no es feriado pues vas a ir a la escuela
no no voy a ir a la escuela porque nos
pusimos de acuerdo con todas mis
compañeras imagínense la tradición que
era eso
vos vas a la escuela
vivía a media cuadra después llorando y
me dijo y si no hay clases de volver es
porque decidió la escuela que no hay
clases vos bueno gramos 32 más que nos
mandaron al restante no nos dieron
clases a las 3 lo vi ahí estuve
enojadísima con él durante mucho tiempo
pero bueno después me di cuenta lo que
me quiso enseñar con eso
como también me dejó su última su último
ejemplo no les conté que un papá en toda
su actividad que tuvo fue una persona
que hizo todo por el fundador de toda
esta gran empresa y de muchas cosas en
la región
los últimos diez años de su vida lo paso
a una ficha de ruedas
con la enfermedad con una salud muy
deteriorada
con falta de movilidad dependía de
nosotros de algún enfermero para que nos
llevemos y que nunca de caso nunca se
preguntó por qué a mí nunca dejó de
trabajar lo hizo hasta el último día de
su vida en su rutina
y así lo pudo demostrar cuando ya fue el
último día de su vida
tuvo una descompostura una neumonía lo
trajimos a belleville
ya estaba que no podía seguir y bueno
después de unas cuantas horas el médico
aceptó un traslado porque veía que
seguía viviendo pero pensó bueno ya no
hay más nada que hacer no puede pensar
hace 12 horas que está sin oxígeno
y cuando sale lo van a cargar en la
ambulancia él me ve a mí se saca su
mascarilla de oxígeno y me dijo la
asamblea
porque al día siguiente había sombría de
agrometal y yo no podía faltar a la
asamblea bueno él nos enseñó entonces
con su vida con su fortaleza con su
interés ante la enfermedad de que nada
en la vida se hace
nada grande en la vida se hace con
excusas
como soy en la empresa como soy en mi
actividad profesional soy también por
supuesto en mi casa
trato de que las cosas salgan siempre
bien
pero bueno a veces son un poquito pesada
hago todo hago mil tareas a la vez
y las hice desde que mis niños eran
chiquitos a todos les de la teta hasta
el año aún trabajando los acompañe al
escuelas y más deberes borde de
lentejuelas fuimos a patín fuman los
deportes
bueno mil tareas juntas como hacemos la
mayoría de las mujeres por supuesto lo
puedo hacer con la ayuda de mi marido y
en la empresa con la ayuda de un grupo
de gente que tiene los mismos valores y
que tienen los mismos desafíos y que les
gustan enfrentar desafíos como me gusta
enfrentar desafíos a mí me gusta tener
sueños me gustan encontrar siempre soy
bastante positiva siempre busco la luz
siempre veo la luz al final de las
posibilidades cuando el encuentro
bueno cuando el encuentro es el pienso
con otro desafío
sin excusas uno tiene que ponerse los
objetivos y sin excusas por eso el
mensaje y la huella que yo le quiero
dejar a mis hijos y a todos los jóvenes
es que se apasionen que busquen un sueño
que los busquen sus desafíos y que se
larguen a encontrar a alcanzar esos
sueños sin excusas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]